und jetzt filme wenn das geht
ich lege jetzt mein handy immer in dein
zimmer und dann höre ich alles was du
sagst ausgedacht und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video
ja aber ich hoffe natürlich jedes gut
heute mal wieder angewöhnt boden
gewöhnlicher naturelle umgebung genau
und zwar eigentlich heute wieder in
fahrt von virale täter gleich sechs
eingesetzt ich habe mir allerdings
gedacht dass ich jetzt in letzter zeit
ich habe schon viel falsch gemacht haben
so irgendwas ist ja auch mal gut
ich bin allerdings wäre die parks
geplant habt auch auf so ein paar facts
gestoßen wo ich mir gedacht habt die
kann man nochmal in einem separaten
video machen weil ich ja sowieso sehr
oft airport zeit ausgepackt habe oder er
vor fakes was auch immer so alles
mögliche wir können uns mal hinsetzen
und ich habe wirklich sachen gefunden
auch auf tik tok vieles ist ein paar
sachen auch einfach bei google ein paar
wusste ich auch schon und ich hab mir
halt gedacht da kann ich eigentlich ein
ganzes video zu machen
heute zeige ich euch heute zeige ich
euch virale airport live hacks von tik
tok google und aus meinem kopf wird
insgesamt fünf stück und das wird kraft
falls du richtig gut kombiniert er
putzen ticket fix
ja kann man also an alle die airports
haben das geht auf jeden fall mit den
originalen
ich hoffe dass alle funktionieren bei
ein bisschen unsicher ob das wirklich
funktioniert mit fakes dann halt nur
begrenzt aber wir können direkt am
anfang mit einem den ich jedes mal
gesehen hab ich habe allerdings nicht
wieder gefunden wo ich den herd kannst
du mal ganz kurz zeigen und zwar dafür
auf jeden fall mit schon mal richtig
fetten daumen nach oben dann wenn ich
jetzt auf gar nichts ein aber wirklich
man möchte sein handy irgendwie einfach
so hinstellen hat kein popstar getragen
sondern möchte einfach so entspannt
gucken und dann fällt sehr sehr sehr um
ich habe jetzt hier ein iphone sieben
plus das ist ja ein ziemlich großes
handy
deswegen geht das nicht ganz so gut aber
es funktioniert und zwar kammern die
airports ganz einfach benutzen um das
auf sein handy hin zu stellen
das lineal oder also das ist so der easy
stair heck den ich auf jeden fall euch
zeigen wollte so hier immer von der
seite vorsichtig rein oder das war gut
und das geht halt mit allen mit allen
airports egal ob das originale sind egal
ob das die 1000 events sind was auch
immer gut das war ein kommen
ich habe jetzt schon mal ganz viele
daumen nach oben von euch abgesahnt für
diese unglaubliche weisheit und jetzt
kommen wir aber zum kranken schnitt also
jetzt wird wirklich krass und ich weiß
auch nicht ob alles funktioniert habe
ich ja schon gesagt
kommen wir zum heck nummer eins und das
ist dieser hass gewalt und du hast es
nicht verstanden was auch nicht erklärt
steen und zwar ich musste mir selber
noch mal kurz anton es ist übrigens
schon heck nummer zwei wir hatten in
schönen ersten pastor lammers ich bin
wirklich gespannt ob es klappt ich das
hier sind meine erfolg so haben wir hier
das heißt die stecke ich mir jetzt in
mein ohr sind automatisch verbunden
hersteller hört sich gut an
und jetzt habe ich hier noch ganz
normale apple kopfhörer aus dem jahr
keine ahnung sind auf jeden fall schon
ein bisschen älter
die kann ich jetzt hier reinstecken und
jetzt können wir praktisch das gleiche
hören weil meine airports beim ein handy
mit dem er fast verbunden ist und die
halt mit dem kopf verbannt verbunden
sind und mit denen in ihr bluetooth
kopfhörern wie auch immer da steht ihr
was meine man kann einfach mit beiden
kopfhörer musik genau gut
zusammengefasst und auch das
funktioniert das checken was mach ich
bin der ganzen sache so ein bisschen
kritisch gegenüber eingestellt
ich hab mal kurzfristig absagen
und jetzt
die mainzer aus dem ort denke ich bin
jetzt schon gespannt auf saftig sich
einen gesichtsausdruck berlin
nein nein nein nein das nicht klappt
nicht bist du dir sicher zu 1000 prozent
jedoch selbst das war was passiert wenn
ich die hier rein mache was soll das
denn ich dachte das geht so safe mode
star da habe ich ja richtig verarscht
ich kann mal wieso soll das auch gehen
ja das wurde mir so viel verkauft und es
wird das geht ja wenn apple das aber
nicht bewirkt so dann geht das auch
nicht aber das war ja einfach verarscht
das wüsstest du doch schon längst ganz
ehrlich nein wirst dich nicht weil ich
würde mal kurz pause ich habe mir jetzt
gerade die kommentare durchgelesen hat
ein video da steht halt dass alle
menschen das wirklich ausprobieren
dummen sind
also ich hätte gedacht das klappt ist so
wie neulich jetzt kannst du scheiße ok
dann kommen jetzt zum nächsten heck da
weiß ich aber dass es klappt und das ist
wirklich krass was auch da freue ich
mich auch schon euch das zu zeigen und
zwar habe ich das bei google gefunden
ihr könnt im juni kommen warum
und zwar habe ich das schon eben
getestet es gibt hier wenn ihr beim
iphone als es in euer kontrollzentrum
geht geht auch mit macbooks könnt ihr
hier steuerelemente anpassen und dann
gibt es hier
er kauft eigentlich unten auf den hat
man eigentlich nicht automatisch
aktiviert hören das kann man hier mit
einbeziehen und dann kann man hier
dieses war zum beispiel betätigen so und
jetzt machen wir folgendes jetzt weil
ich meine airports ins ohr
zack sommer und jetzt wenn du an
gesundheit besteht jetzt alex einzigen
erfasst das sind meine damit ich nicht
durcheinanderkommen live mithören aus
wir machen das und jetzt kann ich mein
handy
ich höre mich jetzt selber
hat offenbar gut man sieht das ja hier
auch an diesen punkten
ich kann jetzt mal ein handy mal bei mir
ins zimmer alter ich kann total
durcheinander
ich kann mein handy bei mir ins zimmer
legen dann hat marie was sie sagt die
krippe ist das ist doch geil ich lege
jetzt mein handy immer in dein zimmer
und dann habe ich alles was du sagst und
das ist sogar richtig gute quali das
stimmt kannst du einfach mal so handy
vergessen aus versehen marie hast du
meine seele sagt gerade ich hab's dir
wohl dahin geschlossen mal ganz leise
da sagt man ganz leicht irgend was man
nicht kann dir sagen was du sagst okay
sagt nein ich höre ich nicht auf
jetzt hast du das gemacht hat jetzt kann
die sonne wieder funktioniert einmal war
ich glaube dass es geht
das geil also leute also leute das
müsste wirklich mal ausprobieren mega
cool
heute ist übrigens sehr wenig raus
gleich kommen können derby wird abgesagt
fc fans aber okay wir kommen zum
nächsten
willkommen zum nächsten leiter des also
das war eigentlich da wo ich gesagt habe
der funktioniert nicht weil ich kann mir
das nicht vorstellen wie das gehen soll
und ich glaube wenn es geht dann falle
ich vom glauben ab warum gerade ich sexy
mal frauen an dem
die ökologie sowie pro passagier hat den
mecklenbecker schweiz
dj pressespiegel meinst du das kann
funktionieren
aber wir haben hier das denn dann
gefällt einfach ein zaun
ok also dass hier sind jetzt meine
airports wir werden jetzt angezeigt hier
sagt und dann ziehe ich dir hier raus
und mach das so
so wie im video war das team wie ich
ganz euch hier ein passauer und jetzt
junge wenn das geht nicht
jetzt halten wir irgendwie leise aber es
da gleich viel zu leise aber es ist
trotzdem verrückt dass das funktioniert
die sind richtig aufgestellt so weit aus
wir haben die auf jeden fall richtig
rein gemacht
ich weiß nicht das ist halt das ist ja
auch schon lustig dass sie so überhaupt
stehen aber es wäre schon geil gewesen
weil die noch lauter gerne aber
technisch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hinter oder hört sich doch gut an
trotzdem finde ich es interessant dass
es überhaupt geklappt hat muss ich sagen
okay deutsche und dann kommen jetzt aus
dem letzten tag der wird ganz krass und
zwar ich habe aber gedacht weil ich
sagte ja auch noch nicht was es ist und
das video was ich dazu gefunden habt
blende ich euch auch erst danach also
nachdem ich das jetzt gleich mache ihr
braucht dafür einfach funktion von
medini müssen gar nicht mir ist
eigentlich egal
also einfach alte apple kopfhörer am
besten und dann geht er kurz in die
küche
du kannst mich nicht will was ich brauch
kurz das so war es wichtig dass wir in
dieser zeit jetzt mal ganz kurz
vorstellen kann abonniert und zweiten
kanal alex kommt täglich neues video
immer so schon vor allem mittags nach
schwule dass ich treffer hast du weißt
du was ich meine erstmals gesehen das
symbol die herzwochen plötzlich denn das
jetzt der fünfte läufe oder wie viel
durch zeichnet man das video dazu
das war der fünfte genau was hast du
gesagt hier gut aus oder kann man das
merkt doch keiner wenn es jetzt nun
darauf ankommen dass andere denken der
von smart es ist jetzt auch noch ein
bisschen spaß und so natürlich sollte
man darauf keinen wert legen aber ich
hab das jetzt mit reingenommen einfach
weiß ja so ein bisschen witzig ist immer
wenn leute airports frage sagen hallo
flex und so
senator roger die herdplatte nicht so
gibt es doch genial leuchten damit
werden wir das video das noch um dafür
weitere papst ganz wichtig aber die den
kanal abonnieren zweiten kanal und wir
sehen uns morgen meist nur wieder gibt's
neues video hat rein